- - On passe au panel avec Michl
DaDavid et Jonathan Trudeau.
BoBonsoir à vous : on va parlere
lala sixième vague. Quand on vot
leles cas qui montent, les chef,
leles nouveaux cas, ça c'est
seseulement léché avec les tests
PCPCR mais c'est quand même la
babarre des 3004 qui a été
frfranchis. Pourtant ça ne sembe
papas beaucoup troubler le
miministre de la santé qui ne vt
papas mettre d'autre mise en ple
CHCHRISTIAN DUBÉ, ministre de la
SaSanté
- - Rien n'empêche d'être beaucp
plplus prudent, et je e dirais
papartout au Québec, mais
paparticulièrement en région
ququ'ils ont pas eu cet effet-l.
AlAlors, c'est des grandes lign.
OuOui on est préoccupé, mais en
mmême temps c'était prévu. Puis,
jeje demande aux gens de continr
àà se protéger, mais il y a
auaucune raison pour le moment..
auaucune raison pour le moment,
dede changer la stratégie qu'ona
paparce que les gens doivent
apapprendre à vivre avec le vir,
cocontinuer à se protéger.
- - Michel, je commence avec vo.
ApAppel à la prudence on le
cocomprend bien symétriquement
babasé sur une responsabilité
inindividuelle. Avec cette famee
phphrase il faut apprendre avece
vivirus. Qu'est-ce que les gens
cocomprennent cette phrase là vs
pepensez?
- - Je pense que les gens comprs
quque finalement le danger était
papassé et qu'on peut faire à pu
prprès ce qu'on veut. On le voi,
momoi je suis allé il n'y a pas
lolongtemps dans un lancement ou
pepersonnes portaient des masqu.
J'J'ai l'impression que les gens
onont l'impression à tort que
c'c'est fini. Le gouvernement et
lele premier responsable de ça.
MaMaintenant, Monsieur Dubé
afaffirme qu'il n'est pas questn
dede prendre des nouvelles
memesures. Je comprends que
popolitiquement ça devient
exextrêmement délicat pour le
gogouvernement de retomber dans
dedes formes de restrictions à a
veveille ou à l'approche des
élélections. Ce serait dramatiq.
OnOn le voit qu'il y a un
mémécontentement qui sait
sésédimenter et qui fait que la
CACAQ dans un sondage récent nos
momontre qu'il y a une chute pas
auaussi importante, mais il rese
quque politiquement ce serait
drdramatique pour le gouverneme.
SiSi on n'en arrive au point où
leles hospitalisations commencet
àà augmenter à coups de 100,200
papar jour je pense que le
gogouvernement va devoir prendre
seses responsabilités.
- - Parce qu'il y a un risque ds
dedeux côtés. Des risques à bour
àà ramener des mesures et des
ririsques à ne pas bouger. Plutt
jeje faisais une entrevue avec
DoDocteur Cécile Tremblay qui
hahabituellement n'est pas une
pepersonne très inquiète, mais
elelle a dit ça augure mal ce qi
s's'en vient devant nous. Parce
quque c'est extrêmement
cocontagieux. Elle elle en appel
auau gouvernement. À prendre des
memesures, à redonner l'accès au
tetest PCR est-ce que vous
trtrouvez-vous ce que le
gogouvernement prend risques ne
bobougeant pas actuellement?
- - Il prend risques mais ce qul
fafaut savoir c'est que dans toe
bobonne gestion des risques quel
esest notre tolérance du risque.
EsEst-ce que le risque est
acacceptable? Quand je parle des
gegens du gouvernement il y a ds
fafacteurs qui sont pris en
cocompte. Le fait que le BA de
commence à être moins virulent.
OnOn connaît des gens qui ont
cocontracté la COVID-19 au cours
dedes derniers jours et Andret i
sosont moins affectés. Je ne
papapillonne pas mais ses
momoindres. On regarde ce qui se
papasse ailleurs dans le monde
cecette vague semble forte maisn
plplateau qui vient assez
rarapidement et qui réduit assez
rarapidement. On dit avec le
prprintemps qui est à nos porte,
onon va ouvrir les fenêtres
rerespirer. Sans oublier que on
nonous dit qu'il y a plus de 3
mimillions de Québécois qui ontu
lala COVID-19 au cours des
dederniers mois. Cette espèce de
prprincipe d'immunité collective
ququi peut commencer à
s's'installer. Est-ce qu'il y an
ririsque politique pour le
gogouvernement? Évidemment, mais
dede là à penser que le
gogouvernement serait suffisammt
irirresponsable pour avoir des
évévidences devant lui et qui mt
lala population en danger que pr
dedes raisons électoralistes il
n'n'en ferait pas gens : ça va a
nene lui fait pas plaisir mais
rarappelons-nous que le Québec t
lala seule province qui garde le
mamasque obligatoire dans l'espe
pupublic. On a été les plus
sésévères depuis longtemps je
pepense qu'on rende un état pont
dodoit augmenter le niveau de
totolérance. C'est ça qu'on estn
trtrain de tester.
- - Vous remarquez que les parts
dede l'opposition ne posent pase
gogouvernement à adopter des
memesures.
MOMONSEF DERRAJI, leader
paparlementaire adjoint du PLQ
- - Si on n'a pas accès aux tess
PCPCR, on risque de rater le bon
mémédicament au bon moment pour
cecertains patients.
JOJOËL ARSENEAU, porte-parole du
PQPQ en matière de santé
- - on n'a pas les indicateurs
adadéquats pour voir l'ampleur
dede la vague actuelle. Et ça,
j'j'en appelle au gouvernement
àà rétablir des systèmes
dede dépistage que ce soit par s
eaeaux usées ou par les tests P.
- - Ce n'est pas un peu étonnant
jujustement, le ministre Dubé
ququand il nous parle de son
trtravail, réformer le monde dea
sasanté il dit qu'il veut mesur,
cacalculer quand on lui parle de
sisixième vague on a l'impressin
ququ'il se prive de données alos
ququ'il pourrait aller en
chchercher. En rendant accessibe
etet est PCR à tout le monde ou
leles élargir à tout le moins. e
fafameux paramétrage où l'on
vévérifie les eaux usées on a
cecessé de le faire au Québec.
PoPourtant ce serait un outil qi
seserait bien pratique. Je
n'n'attends que ça vous étonne?
- - Sur les tests par rapport ax
eaeaux usées je ne comprends pas
popourquoi ça semble être
didifficile de ramener cette
prpratique là. Qui était fort
ututile. Certains ont été surprs
àà quel point ça peut être utile
popour aller étudier ce genre de
dodonnées là. Par contre les tes
PCPCR, il faut comprendre que le
vivirus se propage à une rapidié
tetelle que ça devient impossib.
CeCe n'est pas étranger à ce qun
n'n'a vécu dans la cinquième
vavague, lorsqu'il gouvernementa
adadmis qu'il n'était plus en
memesure de donner des données
fifiables mais qu'il y avait
cecertaines tendances je pense e
c'c'est la même chose. Il y a ds
dodonnées qu'on peut surveillere
pepense à la propagation au nivu
dudu milieu hospitalier. Les
hohospitalisations c'est une
dodonnée qui ne manque pas. Si s
hohospitalisations montent. On
dodoit aussi accepter que moment
dodonné il y aura une propagati.
JeJe répète la même chose, on a
didit collectivement qu'il fallt
apapprendre avec le virus bien
l'l'inconnu fait un peu aussi
paparti de cet apprentissage là.
- - Vous êtes à l'aise avec ça
vovous Michel? Fonctionnait avec
momoins de données.
- - Non pour ce qui est des eaux
ususées je pense que je ne vois
papas pourquoi on s'en passerai.
PoPour ce qui est du PCR, j'ai
l'l'impression que la population
n'n'embarquerait pas. On a pris
l'l'habitude des tests rapides.
LeLes gens s'en satisfont
bebeaucoup. On a tous autour de
nonous des gens qui contactent a
COCOVID-19 ce n'est pas si
drdramatique que ça dans la
plplupart des cas. Alors je pene
quque la tolérance au risque a
auaugmenté dans la mesure où les
gegens considèrent qu'il est mos
imimportant qu'il pouvait l'être
avavant. Pour ce qui est des
hohospitalisations, il reste que
leles Québec et on le voit, de
loloin, la province où il y a la
plplus forte augmentation. C'est
auaussi l'endroit où le systèmee
sasanté est le plus fragile. Ce
n'n'est pas long qu'il y a des
dédébordés. Au moment où on état
auautour de 2000, il y avait des
crcris d'alarme partout. On n'et
papas si loin que ça. C'est au
ryrythme ça progresse. Je pense
ququ'effectivement, le
gogouvernement va avoir si sa pu
sese poursuit un choix extrêmemt
didifficile à faire. Parce que
c'c'est: Damn if you do, Damn if
yoyou don't.
JeJe veux spécifier un outil
dédélégué je veux spécifier nos
tétéléspectateurs je suis loin
d'd'être insensible au risque. e
susuis loin d'être insensible la
prprotection des personnes
vuvulnérables.
LeLe retrait du masque je pense
quque c'est évident qu'on va
rereporter ça. On nous dit que
c'c'est une bonne mesure barrièe
enencore j'ai impression que Van
d'd'avoir leur durée.
- - Il ouvre la porte.
ToTous les deux vous avez fait
réréférence aux risques politiqs
popour Lacquette. Évidemment on
apapprend et on enlève pour les
sosondages mais il y a quand mêe
unun acte qui était intéressant
ququi sortait un point qui 26 %
dedes gens qui votent Sekac
seseraient prêts à voter
coconservateur. Jusqu'à maintent
lele parti conservateur c'est
l'l'opposition à toute mesure
sasanitaire. Il y a vraiment un
efeffet de traction. Est-ce que
c'c'est jujuste la colère, de la
fafatigue pandémique ou les gens
nene veulent plus entendre parlr
dede la pandémie et des mesures
sasanitaires Michel ou quelque
chchose d'autre pour expliquer ?
- - Je pense qu'effectivement
MoMonsieur e a beaucoup profitée
lala fatigue sanitaire. Mais
momoment où on pensait que c'étt
papassablement fini, le parti
coconservateur a continué sa
prprogression. Je pense qu'il a
réréussi à fédérer les mécontens
dede tous ordres. Qui ne sont ps
nénécessairement liées aux mesus
sasanitaires. Ça peut être les
sysystèmes de santé en généralÇa
ppète la crise du logement parce
quque c'est même étonnant de vor
dedes gens, je pense près de 10%
dedes gens que le parti
coconservateur va chercher et qi
viviennent de Québec solidaire.e
grgros de son potentiel ce sont
leles électeurs qui acquiescent.
LeLes liens beaucoup plus facils
àà faire. Je regarde ce sondage
llà, je ne peux pas m'empêcher e
trtrouver que ce sondage qui a é
efeffectué seulement une semaine
apaprès celui de Léger, marque e
énénorme différence. On parle de
lala CAQ à 33 % alors que Léger
aiaimait à 41 %. J'ai beaucoup e
didifficulté à croire qu'en
l'l'espace d'une semaine il y a
plplus avoir un tel glissement.
- - On prend ça avec un grain de
sesel ceci dit il y a quand même
unune élection partielle qui s'n
vivient vite. Marie-Victorin c't
didimanche et lundi, dans quelqs
jojours. Je n'attends ce que
sasavait un indicateur justemen,
rerendre concret ce qu'on voit
dadans les sondages?
- - C'est sûr qu'il y a un test.
OnOn le voit qu'il y a un certan
mémécontentement sur le terrain
dadans Marie-Victorin. Il y a le
PaParti québécois qui a commandé
unun sondage qu'ils ont rendu
pupublic il demande qu'il aurait
unune avance de huit points.
PaParlant des réserves je vais
m'm'en garder une parce que je
pepense qu'on est prêt d'une
égégalité. Je sais que la CAQ au
dedes chiffre qui les mette
gégénéralement en avance.
ClClairement jamais réfère au
LéLéger. Dans les faits quand on
reregarde un peu partout Québec,
onon serait porté à croire que e
seserait facile pour eux dans
MaMarie-Victorin. Or, il y a dex
fafacteurs qui semblent jouer en
fafaveur du PQ. Le Parti québécs
unune très bonne notoriété avec
soson candidat. Pierre Nantel qi
esest un ancien député, qui est
apappréciée une figure connue.
DoDonc lui il fait performer le
PaParti québécois. À l'inverse,a
cacandidate de la CAQ semble avr
dede la difficulté à s'imposer.e
ququi peut avoir pour effet de
titirer un peu vers le bas. Une
chchose est certain c'est que ls
paparties voudront interpréter a
cocomme un signal en vue de la
prprochaine élection. Si Lacquee
l'l'échappe se serait vu comme
ététant un symbole du
mémécontentement. Pour ce qui et
dudu Parti québécois, eux ils
luluttent pour leur survie pour
dédémontrer qu'ils sont capables
enencore de s'imposer. C'est une
lulutte à finir bien malin celui
ququi peut prédire comment ça va
sese terminer.
- - Vos réactions Michel.
- - Je suis quand même un peu
susurpris de ce n'est année-là.e
cocomprends que Monsieur Nantel
esest beaucoup plus connu que ts
leles autres candidats dans Mar-
ViVictorin. Il reste que le Pari
ququébécois est traîné vers le s
dedepuis des mois. Il faudra vor
jeje pense que la participationa
êêtre déterminante. Quelle
ororganisation va réussir à faie
sosortir son vote. Il n'y en aua
prprobablement pas beaucoup, de
mémémoire la dernière partielle
c'c'était de l'ordre de 30 à 40.
CÇa devient beaucoup une bataile
d'd'organisation. Je ne suis pas
cecertain que les gens vont se
prprécipiter vers les urnes.
- - On n'est pas Québec on est à
l'l'anglais. Jusqu'à quel point
c'c'est révélateur. Pour le pari
coconservateur.
- - S'il est parti conservateure
fafait quelque pour cent ou ce
n'n'est vraiment pas sa clientè,
onon peueut penser que dans la
grgrande région de Québec, ils
vovont vraiment performer.
- - Ça va être intéressant suiv.
MeMessieurs c'est déjà terminé.